les commerces non essentiels aux rouvert
ce mercredi 19 mai lusine centre
commercial spécialisé dans la haute
lesse de la mode et de la maison à
vélizy était fermé depuis le 5 mars
c'est un soulagement bien évidemment on
avait besoin les commerçants et nous de
pouvoir à nouveau retrouver nos clients
et puis on est extrêmement confiants
dans notre modèle
au vu du contexte économique des plus
moroses où l'ensemble des acteurs et des
filières de distribution ont été
affectés bien évidemment la houlette
tire son épingle du jeu et pendant cette
crise des stocks dans les magasins se
sont accumulés ici on récupère les
invendus de l'année précédente
dès aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les clients
peuvent bénéficier dans notre centre de
quantité et de qualité de stocks très
importants sur lesquels sont d'ores et
déjà avec des remises et les commerçants
attendait cette réouverture avec
impatience je suis très heureux je suis
très enthousiaste et je suis contente de
retrouver le centre et toutes nos
petites clientes sont au rendez vous etc
mais c'est super qu'on est très très
content ici dans le sang il ya beaucoup
de clientes fidèles
les clients eux étaient présents dès
l'ouverture à vous r je suis ravi pour
les commerçants qui puisse enfin aurait
ouvrir leurs magasins et avoir une
activité pouvoir avant tout leurs
produits
oui on va cueillir avant tout des
clients revivre un peu normalement je
dois abîmé dossier pour un mariage et je
préfère
aller sur place dans un magasin pour
essayer surtout pour des enfants change
beaucoup de taille de retrouver le
chemin des magasins ça fait du bien
voilà j'étais content de pouvoir le
faire ouvert habituellement du mardi au
dimanche le centre accueillera
exceptionnellement du public ce lundi 24
mai